Hello. Welcome to today's episode of Rawkode live.
I'm your host, Rawkode.
Today, we're gonna be taking a look at
Kaniko, a tool for building container images in
Kubernetes.
Now before we get started, this is a
little bit of housekeeping. First, if you're not
already subscribed,
rude, but you should subscribe now and click
that bell. This helps other people find the
content, plus you'll get notifications for each of
the new episodes coming up.
Also, if you're not watching live and you
have questions or you want to make suggestions
for new technologies to
cover on Rawkode Live, then you can join
the Discord. There's a few hundred people that
a few hundred people that are now talking
about cloud native Kubernetes and everything in between.
So come and say hello.
And lastly, I wanna thank Equinix Metal, my
employer, for allowing me to do this. You
can check out Equinix Medal
using the code Rawkode. This will get you
$200
of compute. That's anywhere from fifty hours to
four hundred hours depending on the machine that
you choose. So, you know, have fun or
use it wisely. That is up to you.
Now today, to introduce us to Kaniko, I
am joined by from
the Google Container team. Hi there.
Hi, David.
Thank you for having me. No. The pleasure
is all mine. I'm looking forward to playing
mechanical today and showing that to our to
the people that are watching. Do you wanna
just take a moment to tell us a
little bit about yourself, and then we'll get
started?
Yeah. Sure.
So my name is Tejal.
I was born and raised in India.
I came to United States for my master's
a decade ago maybe.
And after completing my masters, I've been working
as a software engineer.
I've been working at Google since pretty much
last
five years,
mostly in container developer experience
and
container tools.
I'm currently the maintainer of Kaniko,
and I'm actually working on another awesome container
development tool, which is Scaffold.
I
manage Scaffold at Google now.
Awesome. I'm
a big fan of Scaffold as well, actually.
It's a really cool tool
and Kaniko. So I'm looking forward to Yeah.
Pulling both these tools off. I actually have
someone from the Scaffold team joining me next
week to do an episode there. Yes. That'll
be awesome too.
Yes. Alright. Do you want to just will
we start with a a little bit of
a brief introduction? It's just like what is
Kaniko and and what is it for?
Sure.
So Kaniko
was
started at Google maybe around three years ago
as a way
to build
images in your cluster securely.
Before Kaniko,
people used to actually install Docker inside their
cluster.
And,
you know, Docker
inside the cluster is not a great idea.
It has a lot of, you know, security
concerns because you expose the Docker socket. So
anybody
could tap in and, you know, just just
take
advantage
of the Docker socket and
end up, you know, corrupting your Kubernetes
cluster or, you know, send a malicious
run malicious code or anything like that.
So for that reason, Kaniko
started as
starter project
one of the projects that, you know, in
Google, you end up giving to a new
engineer.
But we found out that it has a
lot of potential. That was something that was
missing in the market, and people adopted it
and became one of the popular tools now.
So Kaniko lets you help build container images
inside the cluster
without the need of Docker.
So
what it does is,
it spins up a a container
and runs all the commands in your Dockerfile.
It'll run it on the operating sys on
the container itself
and detect
what changes
a particular command run ended up doing to
your file system
and would build
image layers
based on those changes
and then produce
Docker image.
Okay. I think I understand some of that.
So let me try and repeat some of
that back. So
I I understand that running Docker inside of
Kubernetes is is not a good idea because
we have the Docker socket that allows people
to do bad things with their containers, particularly
in the older days where Docker had to
run its root. I know there's some changes
and advancements there.
Then Kaniko came along and tried to provide
a a secure way to do this.
Now
so does Kaniko still launch containers for each
of the layers or is it doing something
magic within the existing container? Like, I'm I
don't think I understand exactly what's happening there.
That's a good point. So let let's dig
into the internals of Kaniko. So
you actually spin up as
a bill as someone who wants to build
image, you would spin up a pod,
which runs a Kaniko container image.
Kaniko
itself does not spin up any container images
or or any containers to build individual layers.
What it does is on your container, executes
the commands in your Dockerfile.
So
if there is the first command of your,
Dockerfile is from, then it'll go and,
given that the Kaniko container has access to
your image repository,
will go pull
the image, the base image, and then,
you know,
untar it and extract it.
Then it'll take a snapshot of your file
systems.
Now we'll run the next command in your
Docker file
If it is
meta command, which is just like, you know,
sending work directory or setting user permissions,
then it doesn't do anything
much.
It'll only update the
image manifest
and metadata in the image.
But if it is a docker run command,
which actually ends up manipulating the file system
and adding new files or generating new files,
Kaniko will run that. It's as
whatever user you've set it to run as,
and then it'll take a snapshot of your
file system now. So with
the snapshotting mechanism, it can detect
what were the changes that happened between your
first command Dockerfile command and the next Dockerfile
command.
And then it'll pull up all those changes,
create a image layer
out of it.
Okay.
So
in my naive understanding then, is it fair
to say that Kaniko is, like, doing a
char root and with the layer file and
then running a command? Is that in a
really simple term? I'm sure there's more going
on. But
In the simple term, yes. It is actually
executing the commands in your Docker file
and figuring out what changed.
Okay.
Cool.
That actually helps a lot with just the
the basic understanding of of how it's putting
this together. I think it maybe is important
to note for the the viewers at home
then is that there's nothing particularly special about
a container image. Right? They're just literally what
you said is a bunch of tarballs that
happen to have some JSON manifest data to
tell it
ordering and semantics and metadata and that's it.
There's nothing particularly special. Cool.
Awesome. Then I think what we'll do is
we'll jump over to the screen share
and we'll try and build a container image.
I say try. I should have more confidence,
shouldn't I? It's like, we will build a
container image. Alright.
So this is the Kaniko GitHub repository.
It's available at github.com/googlecontainertools/kaniko.
There is lots of documentation. I noticed as
I was kinda poking around
earlier.
I'm assuming we're just gonna go to the
tutorial to get started. Does that sound fair?
Let's do that. Alright.
Okay. So
the getting started tutorial or are we scrolling
down this page?
I think let's get to the getting started
tutorial.
Okay. So prerequisites.
Kubernetes cluster, check. I have
a Kubernetes cluster.
I also have Docker for Mac if we
need to fall back on that for whatever
reason.
I do have a Docker Hub account if
we need to get the token for that.
I'll do that sneakily over here.
But I think two texts on the prereqs,
which
means we can just go jump straight out
and build a container image.
Yeah.
Before that, we need to actually
mount your source code
onto,
you know, your Kubernetes clusters. So I think
the several
next configuration
files that are there,
the pod dot yaml, the volume, and the
volume claim helps you do that.
Okay.
So let's see what this is. Let me
just zoom in on that a little bit.
So this is just a part called Kaniko
that runs the Kaniko executor.
Just looking for some volume there. Yes. So,
Kaniko, go for it.
The interesting part is from line eight onwards
where we are actually mounting your secret as
well as we are also mounting
storage
where you would end up
mounting the source code that you wanna build.
Okay.
So if I'm using a remote Kubernetes cluster,
is that a problem?
No. It shouldn't be.
Alright.
Okay. So you just want me to copy
this and save it locally. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. And this is just gonna
be our pod dot yama. I did pop
open codes so we can just
the new file.
Save as pod
dot yama.
And we need the two other ones. So
here is my volume.
So just
so that I understand.
Mhmm.
So I understand.
Is there a CLI element to Kaniko that
I execute on my local machine?
No. Kaniko cannot be executed
in your local machine.
It has a binary,
but the the Kaniko
design is based on the fact that you're
running it inside a container, and it ends
up entering your root file system,
manipulating your root file systems,
and deleting certain things and, you know, registering
certain special directories.
And if you run Kaniko
on your
local machine, we might end up
deleting
certain files, which is something that you would
not wanna do. Yeah. That is, like, a
terrible idea. Okay. So I do see that
we're using host path here in a persistent
volume.
So if I'm working with a remote cluster,
how do we get the data into that
location?
That is a good question.
I think this
this tutorial actually
assumes that you are
running in a remote cluster.
Let me go back and check.
Oh, no. Okay. So once we get the
SSH into the cluster,
I think, just to provide the build. Yeah.
Okay. We can do that. Yeah. That's not
a problem. Okay.
And it wants me to create the secret.
I'll do that when we get there then.
So first things first is we just want
to go on to one of the machine.
Mhmm.
Okay.
I guess if I use Docker for Mac,
that's not really a problem.
No.
If if you wanna run Kaniko in right
now as a docker container, it's just one
docker in command.
It's not part of the tutorial,
but it is on the read me, and
we could try that first and then switch
to this flow.
I I think we can just use the
so the Docker for Mac shops with a
Kubernetes API that handles all the volume as
far as. I reckon we just go with
that and see what happens. Okay. So we'll
we'll stick with the tutorial. I'll just pop
up in Docker. I'll make sure I'm on
the right context.
I'm just gonna try it as it is.
So if I just
that also means I won't have to set
up
the registered token secrets either. So, you know,
double win.
So what we want here is
oh, I don't know the MAC pass. I
really should know that. Let me get that.
So I'll call this context.
I think that's what the tutorial roughly said
and then I'll copy this.
And that should
just work.
I'm saying that as a question and a
statement at the same time. So you can
tell how confident I am. But
I reckon we'll be okay. And if not,
we'll work around it. Okay. So Okay. This
says okay. It says create Kaniko. I've got
context. That's fine. And then wants me to
create a very simple Docker file
that I can do.
Command
forgot how to Docker.
There you go.
Entry Docker.
I'm doing well today. Alright. This this is
my context.
Docker.
Well,
I created a context there. There we go.
That looks better.
That's actually suggesting Ubuntu bash echo hello. I
think we'll be okay with mine. If not,
we can blame me for breaking.
Okay. Now it wants a secret. Now because
we're using Docker for Mac, I think
I can just sneakily log in over here.
I was worried that when I take my
password into one password, it's magically just gonna
show up somewhere because I'm on the wrong
box. But I think I was okay.
It's not showing up.
It's just I I think I've I've flashed
a password twice on this show now. It
wouldn't be the end of the world. Okay.
So let's confirm my hypothesis before we move
on.
Oh, I'm in the wrong context.
Oh, no.
Oh, I probably have with this.
Even I I said that things go wrong
and it's always me, that was no word
of a lie.
Okay.
Here we have.
No. Okay. We'll see what happens.
Okay. Let's let's assume that I've got maybe
everything working and it may work.
Now
are we just moving straight down to the
create resources in Kubernetes section, which is just
to create, I guess, those three YAML files
that we've set locally inside of our Kubernetes
cluster?
Yep.
Oh,
it should really be in the right directory.
Okay.
No. I wish I'd given them better names
too.
Oh, it's three f's isn't it when you
do it.
There. Okay.
So
get pods.
And
I'll assume Kaniko was just
pending because we're pulling the image and not
because I've made a mistake.
No. It could be because there is something
wrong
going.
So it's still
Oh, okay. It's complaining about my
volume claim.
Mhmm.
Alright. I guess I'm debugging already. Okay.
Docker fail.
Local storage.
Oh, come on, Docker for Mac. Why are
you being mean?
Well, it's just bound now. Was it just
slow?
Yeah.
Oh, great.
Yeah. I was I I wasn't worried. No.
Not at all.
Yeah. Container creating
would mean we're pulling an image hopefully. So
we'll give that just a few seconds and
we'll see what happens.
And
we'll see what the tutorial tells us to
do.
Mhmm. So it's suggesting we just take a
look at the
Kaniko logs. Oh, so well,
there's something I hadn't realized then. So
by applying the pod dot yaml, we have
now actually triggered a build. Is that correct?
That is correct. So Kaniko
executor is the entry point for the container
image that
you just created a container for,
and it's gonna start executing
the build.
Okay. Let's see if it's still pulling orbit.
Maybe.
Yeah. Successfully assigned.
Oh, the volume. Oh, the red grid.
Alright. I was hoping Docker for Mac was
just gonna take care of that for me.
But we I should learn by now never
to skip a step in the tutorial.
Alright. I will also do that in secret.
And you said that as our
the push into a container registry isn't our
only option as well. There's a few other
ways that we can work with the built
image?
Correct. We can. We can create a tar,
and then,
you know, skip pushing by using a flag.
No called no push.
And is that something
that you see often,
or is that pretty much standard just to
push it straight to a registry of Kin?
There are a few folks who requested that
plot. I'm not sure what the use case
was, but the standard use case is pushing.
Okay.
So
I have created the secret, the Docker server.
I don't know if it said it in
the docs. Is that just Docker? No. No.
I have to use this.
It's gonna say, of course, it says in
the docs.
Let me fix that.
Edit secret.
It's all weird. Alright. I need to just
recreate it.
That's what I get for just thinking. I
could type docker.io
and get away with it.
Okay. I've created a new secret.
So
I don't know if I'll need to
should I maybe delete the pod or do
you think we can just give it a
little bit of time and it'll
work out what's going on?
Let's give it a little bit of time.
Think it should be recovering.
Maybe
the scheduler will just
be, you know, delay
the retrial.
It's still saying not found.
The
secret Rashgrid does exist.
Yeah.
K.
Forty
seconds ago.
You're much more you're much more patient than
I. I would have deleted this part of
my
Start again. Yeah. Why not? Just apply in
a pod. Well, in theory, we should see
it spin up pretty quickly because it has
already pulled the image and the secret should
exist.
I think also in the pod definition, was
there few things that we had to substitute?
Yeah. Here, the destination
needs to be substituted with your username and
repo,
line number 11.
Uh-huh. Okay.
Rawkode,
Kaniko demo. Would that work this time?
Yeah.
I don't think we need to change anything
else. Yeah. It's even nicely commented for me.
Again, just not paying enough attention.
And
this allow just works. This is the name
of my secret. Okay. Let's
let's try that one more time then.
There it is. It is pulling the image.
Yeah.
It looks much better. There we go. It's
running and everything.
I
guess we expect because this is just a
pod executing a single task. It's either gonna
say complete and I've not messed anything else
up. Yeah. Also would have said error and
I probably
had a little tear, but we're okay.
So
this is now built.
Correct. So file.
Right.
We could now look at the Kaniko Podlogs
to see what got build and what was
the image pushed and if there were any
issues in the build.
All info. I
mean, I'm pretty confident that worked.
It should work. You should see a image.
You should be able to pull it.
Oh, yeah. I could just run it. Right?
Docker run
RM Rawkode
Rawkode.
Kaniko
demo.
And I'm assuming because I never specified or
tag, is it using latest or is that
something I should have specified?
No. It should push to latest.
I
think it kinda worked.
Okay.
Except for I didn't get my actual echo
hello. Yeah.
I was confused about that too.
So that could just again,
me not doing things very correctly. So why
don't we make them change to our Docker
file?
So
Alpine uses ash,
dash c is the same as bash, and
then o echo.
Okay.
So
I can just well, I can't reapply this
because we'll have an existing pod. Is that
right? So I'd probably just have to delete
that anyway.
Oh, no. It doesn't seem to Oh.
Oh, I haven't changed anything.
Yeah.
I'll clean it up. Oh, yeah.
Zero
force and
apply again.
And I'm assuming if we just watch that,
we'll see it.
Can I just I can just watch the
logs from there, right? Yeah.
I see the Docker file is now pushing.
Okay.
Let's try again.
Oh,
docker image.
I don't know why my container is not
talking to me. But I'm feeling slightly hurt
because of it.
Should I I
think what I'll I'll just copy this one.
Maybe that would be a good idea.
Okay. Let's I'm not sure. Oh, no. You
know what? I am just being really silly
today. We're not gonna see the output if
we don't assign it to you to why.
Maybe?
No.
Okay. Clearly, I just have no idea what
I'm doing. Okay.
Let's try it one more time.
I
will have a container say hello to me
if it's the last thing I do today.
Logs.
Started
yet.
There.
Still
pretty quick considering it was pulling an Ubuntu
image. That was a lot faster than I
was actually expecting that to be.
Let's just pull the latest
tag. Yeah. It's a bit bigger now.
I guess they've been to images. It must
be available for some weird reason. I
guess. And I said There it is.
I have I don't know what's wrong with
the Alpine one. I'm I'm I'm not gonna
dwell on it but
I'll bet I lose sleep over it later.
Okay.
Cool.
That's it. We built an image.
Yeah. So I think one of the mostly
used feature of Kaniko is the caching feature.
Kaniko
caches images and only runs command
if the command has changed.
So
when I say caches images, it means it'll
end up caching the intermediate layers
based on your command and then few other
things that we
find out if the previous commands of previous
lines have changed, which could end up affecting
the current Dockerfile command or not. And then
based on that, we will either use the
image from
the layer cache
if it's
something that we think that nothing
has changed. If things have changed, then we'll
rebuild it.
So a lot of folks,
you know, use that feature.
We cache the copy command and the run
command.
Run command has the greatest advantage because that
just means that if you're actually,
you know, installing
things from,
you know, PIP install or anything crazy with
AppGet,
then if we already know that a particular
layer is cached, then we'll not run AppGet
blah blah blah and, you know, install. We'll
just take it from the cache.
So we could try that command
with a more complex,
Docker file.
Yeah. So
where is that cache part of either of
these
volume claims, or is that doing something else
there? Like, where does that
caching information live within the cluster?
That's a good question. We currently
support remote caches only. So Ah. We you
can specify
what your
cache
you know, where you would want your cache
to live on the remote.
We if you do not specify it, we
make a guess.
It's just based on your destination
and then slash cache.
That's where all the caches would be.
There is an outstanding feature to support,
you know,
caches
persistent caches,
but
we just haven't had time to actually go
implement it.
Okay. Yeah. That makes a lot of sense.
So is it fair to kind of
is is it like the cache from parameter
where you can specify another image when if
I were using, like, the Docker CLI? Is
that kind of what the remote cache is
like with Kaniko?
So you have to specify,
it as a flag for the Kaniko executors.
So if you look at the pod right
now here, like, you have dash dash destination,
there is a flag called cache destination probably,
and then minus minus cache, which is which
will turn on, caching true. I might be
wrong on the cache destination. Maybe you'll have
to go to the read me.
Yeah. Oh, yeah. Let's see. Forget it. Let's
you're right. Let's get a slightly more advanced
Dockerfile,
and we'll try out the caching. Is that
let's see. Is that gonna show up here
in this tutorial, or should we need to
No. Okay. No. We have to go to
Okay.
So if I just search for cache,
we get all of these flags. Okay.
So we've added cache through. I'm assuming cache
repo
or cash dir.
So again, cash dir and cash repo
are optional.
If it's not provided, then we just make
a best guess based on your image repository.
Right. Okay.
So I I don't even need this parameter
then. I can just do dash dash cache,
and it's gonna work out the best way
to do this probably.
Okay.
So if I grab my Dockerfile and that
it probably helps that it moves to Ubuntu
now, so we can do something in which
we would consider relatively
heavy,
which would be like an app installed then.
I'll just make it in fact, we'll bring
this one in next. Let's let's run this
first one first. Does that make sense? And
then we'll add in your app commands and
I guess what you're saying is if we
view the logs of the Kaniko build executor,
we'll just see it saying skipping the step
or using the cache or something similar.
Yep.
Okay.
Let's apply that.
Run get pods.
And
not quite yet.
There we go.
Well, it looks like did it
you have a cache there?
No. In this case, it did not because
this is the first time you're building. So
we only have a cache per
image. So if
if you
it's this is not a global cache. It's
just for your repository. Right? Yeah.
Yes. So it just says it was checking
for a cache, but it doesn't find one.
We can now see it running.
Mhmm. Oh,
I didn't specify
the
the yes flag.
Let
me delete and apply one more time.
So I I'm curious then,
Are there any
based on the way that the executor works
where it's fetching the image, extracting it,
doing some sort of chirou in a command
run.
Mhmm. Does that mean that if I want
to build the
an ARM image, I have to use an
ARM
Kubernetes node to do that?
Yes.
Currently,
we
do not support cross platform builds.
Again,
a lot of people ask for it.
We also have multi arch Kaniko images. So
right now, if you look at our release
page, we end up publishing Kaniko images for
ARM and
AMD,
64,
and then maybe one more that I'm missing.
But, yeah, you could you basically need to
run on a cluster of that target type.
If you are building Go images, then we
have a way to specify the arcs,
like custom platform,
and
then you would have to add that. Write
a Docker file where you said the Go
OS and, you know,
Go Arch, the right
ARC and operating systems, and do a cross
platform build
support which is supported by Go.
Okay. I think we had a small problem
there, and I don't think Docker Hub, like,
was trying to push to slash cache.
Oh, okay.
I I I don't know if that's expected,
but I I see the yellow one. I'm
kind of like, oh, maybe not. And it
says fail to push.
Oh, is it because
you already have something over there or it
shouldn't happen? Never seen this.
Well, I don't think Docker supports
the slash username slash repo slash something else.
At least I've never seen that before.
Oh, okay.
Then you could use the destination
parameter,
the cache d I r or let's see.
Oh, yes. So I can set a flag
to specify a local directory for cache for
patient issues.
So this cache d I r is just
for caching base images.
So a lot of people,
especially in CICD case, you know, you your
base image is the same. Right? You don't
have to pull it every single time. So
you could we also provide
we could get into that later, but we
also provide a way to load your base
images.
And then instead of pulling it during your
build, we'll just
reference it from that
destination directory cache d a DIR.
What we need for caching is the cache
repo flag.
Alright. Okay. So we can actually
dash dash cache.
We can just override where it's gonna store
the cache for that. Right.
Oh, let me do that. See.
I could just say Rawkode mechanical demo cache.
Yeah.
Okay.
Cool. That makes sense. So let's delete our
old pod.
But I'm
gonna assume just with the delete pod, create
pod, delete pod. Can is it Kaniko a
tool that you expect people to run-in a
local dev environment, or is it targeted more
at machine automated CICD kind of processes?
Mostly for
it's it's used mostly in GitHub workflows and
Tekton CD pipeline for CICD cases.
For local, usually, you know, Docker build
is fastest.
Enterprise users who don't allow Docker
to be built on developer machines can also
use Kaniko.
Yeah. I can see how this has worked
really well with with Tekton actually just with
its ability to kind of create
those pods as the the workflows or the
jobs come in and then build those. Yeah.
Right.
I definitely picked something that was
time intensive to cache because
it's a bit longer than I expected it
to be.
Nice. Pushing it now.
Perfect.
Yeah. It seems a lot happier this time.
Maybe. I guess my upload is not as
fast as my download speed.
Yeah. We go.
Think you're building a big image.
Yeah. I'm I'm I'm really regretting my decision
to to say to install them into this.
However,
I feel like we're committed now. So.
We could
install something light next time and see. Make
sure that it's not cached.
Alright. So
does that mean if I delete our pod
and I just create that as is, is
it it's just gonna use the cache and
not do anything. Is that kind of what
we would expect to see?
Yes. That is that should be what
that should happen. Let's see if it happens
or not.
Should is is my favorite word on this
show. That's for sure.
And cache there. There we go.
So
This was much faster than our previous run.
So we can delete that. We could continue
to iterate on our Dockerfile
knowing that Mhmm. As long as we don't
modify
these cached layers
and only add stuff to the bottom, we
should always be able to leverage that cache
for faster builds.
Right. Just the cache is based on I
mean, is this just like
you just create a a shasham or something
of each of these instructions? I think you
said earlier that Right.
Internally,
we do create, like, a
shasham
of what the instruction is, and it's also
keyed on the
commands above.
Because sometimes, you know, a previous run
could end up, you know, changing the
files the consequences for the next following run
up. So if the previous cache
previous command also changes, we take that into
account by, you know, keying
the cache the hash keys for command seen
so far.
Awesome.
I think that's all very cool to know
that I can do this safely
inside of my Kubernetes cluster without resorting to
any,
you know, privileged containers or any Docker sockets
or anything like that. Just have something that
I know is is secure and safe.
Is there any other features of Kaniko you'd
like us to quickly take a look at?
Sure. So we could go to,
the read me.
So like I said,
you know, Kaniko ends up taking a snapshot
before the command run,
after the command run to figure out, like,
what file changed.
The default snapshotting
strategy, I think if you could go at
the
end of the read. Maybe explain a little
bit about,
what are the snapshotting strategies,
in the snapshot mode.
There is a full snapshot,
which actually ends up also
hashing the file contents of all the files,
which could be
time consuming.
So we have three snapshot strategies.
This is something that we ended up doing,
especially for
projects like, if you're building,
no n p if you're running NPS,
or node install and it or app,
you end up generating a lot of files.
Right? And then we are actually hashing the
contents of these thousand files.
So
snapshot full
wasn't very,
you know, fast
enough for users. Like, it would end up
snapshotting for maybe fourteen or fifteen minutes. So
we ended up,
you know, introducing another snapshot mode, is redo,
which ends up actually only
hashing the metadata about the file, like the
time, the size it was motivate size
and time it was created or modified,
owners and blah blah blah. So,
it is big it has proved to be
50% faster.
Nice. And then there is another one which
is just time based on m time, but,
again, there are certain, you know, limitations related
to m time because, you know, time can
move forward and pad like, time can jump
around.
So
those are a few things that you could
if you see, like, your build is slower,
I would suggest try the snapshot mode.
Cool.
So is the snapshot filled yeah. That is
the default. It says here. Okay. Yeah. It
is the default. It works for most of
the cases, but only for Node. Js projects.
We've seen, like, peep people have complained about
the snapshotting time.
I guess that's because of that huge Node
modules directory that a lot of these Node.
Js projects have. Correct.
Yeah. Yeah. I I I think that's just
a a general problem I hear when I
speak to people at conferences when that was
a thing is that working with
it was always kind of interpreted languages never
compiled and the amount of files and vendor
stuff that they have going on was always
kind of difficult in Docker build steps.
Yeah, I understand that.
Yeah. Is there anything else you wanna cover?
Sure. I think
one thing,
we have we support a bunch of registries.
We also
support something called as reproducible flag,
which is
a lot of people do end up using
it
in
production if they would want to make sure
that the image is reproducible.
So
we end up stripping the time stamps of
the built images so you could exactly
compare two images and understand if there are
any file changes or not.
So
I think Google,
we have a base image repository project
where
we end up publishing,
like, you know,
images that you could use
with
just, like, minimal things, and we use the
reproducible
flag over there, to create those images so
people,
can end up understanding,
what were,
the differences, and it's always reproducible.
The
time doesn't change for the image,
built.
There's single snapshot. You could create, like, one
snapshot of the entire,
Docker file, instead of, like, having those intermediate
image layers.
There are a bunch of flags that, you
know, you could just
go and see. But the interesting thing is
about the cache warmer. So we have if
you go to our release page
it's a little bit out
here.
So we have
a bunch of images available.
There is executor, which what which is what
we're trying right now. There is a debug
image, which only has the busy box
installed in it, so you get the shell.
So if you wanna debug your Dockerfile or
debug your builds, you might end up using
the demig debug image.
So you could run all the, shell commands
available.
There is slim,
which is something that,
was requested with Tekton.
I think with the executor,
image, we bundle a bunch of binaries. Like,
we support different types of context, not just
local store local file, but even, like, you
could pull a git context,
Azure,
GCS,
and we end up, like, bundling a lot
of binaries,
for those. For Tekton, usually, like, the the
code is checked out and everything
needed is already present. So slim,
works for the for them, because all you
need is the Kaniko
binary.
And then we have if you go down,
actually,
warmer image. This is the cache warmer. It's
not on the release page. But the cache
warmer could be used to download
your base images.
So when you are perform and mount them,
store them
in
volume storage for your Kubernetes cluster. And then
when performing build, all the base images
would be extracted from
that one mount and wouldn't be pulled. So
you could again make your CI build faster
because, generally, your base images
remain same.
You know, you would upgrade them once in
a while. So you would first, whenever you
wanna upgrade your base image, just suppose you
were on go 10 and now you're increasing
the version, then you run the egg the
cache warmer executor once
to download your new base images in a
cache directory. And then from then on, you
just use the executor to reference those base
images.
Yeah. That makes sense as well.
So
I guess this is something that if I'm
running if I, you know, if I wanna
use my Kubernetes cluster to be building
all of my container images in a in
a CI step, like,
because this is all, like, mechanical executors can
find a single part and it is working
on its own and it's pushing to remote
caching and stuff, like, I could scale these
just horizontally by as however many bells I
need to run at any one point in
time?
Yes. You can.
If you have a lot of notes,
there shouldn't be a scheduling problem. You could
run as many, as you want in parallel.
And is Tekton the approach that you encourage
people to use to
to use Kaniko? Or, you know, are you
using just a a straight up Kaniko? Like,
is there is there a decision to be
made there, how do I make that decision?
So Tekton, I think, is more of an
orchestrator.
So you could end up
designing your pipeline.
For the build step in your Tekton pipeline,
Kaniko is recommended
or one of the builders that you could
use.
Kaniko
GCB, Google Cloud Build, also support Kaniko. So
you could run
a Kaniko build on GCB
and
take advantage of all the caching.
I know a lot of users, Kaniko users
use
GitLab workflow.
I haven't looked into it personally,
but there is a tutorial dedicated to Kaniko
on
the GitLab.
People fix a bunch of issues related to
that in Kaniko.
Yeah. As someone who has used Gitlab CI
an awful lot over the last however many
years,
getting the Docker builds to work on it
was always an absolute pain. And looking for
something like this would have made my life
a lot easier.
Definitely for sure. Okay.
I think I've got like one more question
and then if there's anything else you wanna
cover, we'll do that.
Mentioned Sure. During our chat just a little
bit ago that
can I you said a git context for
the build?
I can use a git repository for the
build context. So I guess that would remove
that persistent volume claim mounting thing. That something
that's just supported in Vanilla Kaniko, or there's
nothing else I need to do there?
Well, you need to provide your Git credentials
so that we could check out your Git
repository. But if you go a little bit
up
in the read me, there is a section.
If you go to the top of the
read me,
you would see the link for
Kaniko build context.
And
there are
these are the context that we end up
supporting, GCS,
s three, Azure.
Because Kaniko is open source,
you know, a lot of developers who are
using
Amazon,
AWS,
or Azure, Microsoft,
they end up they have ended up contributing
these
features to Kaniko.
Okay. So
that means let me just okay. So I
could just drop a get URL into
new Your part.
This yeah. Yeah. That's it. Right? Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, awesome. Yeah. Okay. That actually helps just
understand how I would actually use this I
think a bit more. But
I can provide a secret for private get
repositories. I'm assuming for open source repositories. I
don't hopefully maybe need to provide anything there.
Could just drop in my Git URL and
see build this and then it would just
go away, work, and I'd be quite happy.
Okay.
Yeah. That that makes a lot of sense.
Cool.
We covered quite a lot there. Is there
anything else you wanna cover before I let
you go back to your day?
No.
Nothing that I can think of.
No. That's quite alright. I think what we've
what we've done is we've had a really
good look at Kaniko and how it works.
I love the the simplicity of it, the
way that it works, and it it's the
caching thing I think is really cool and
having the flexibility to tweak those cache parameters
and how I want them to work to
speed up build teams is particularly useful as
well. So let me just move
my screen.
Awesome.
Well, thank you very much for joining me
today. It was nice to kinda be guided
through Kaniko,
show people how to get involved, how to
get started.
I'm assuming as it's an open source project
that people can come to the repository,
find some simple issues, help contribute, and and
be a part of the community? Yeah.
Yeah. We I am the maintainer. I end
up, like,
releasing
every month.
So I look for
maybe today, third week of every month, I
go through pull request. I help people get
those over the finish line if needed.
And, again, like, we have issues, triage, and,
you know, what labels help one day, like
the general open source
logistics. And then, you know, you get anyone
can pick any any
issue they want and
add features to Kaniko.
Awesome. Alright. Well, people should definitely get involved.
Check that out. Have a play and let
us know how you get on. Tajal, thank
you for joining me today. I hope you
have a great rest of your day, and
I will speak to you again soon.
Yep. Thank you so much for having me.